I know in my legs I have no legs I'm all
torso I've got nothing
so if I don't put 75 pillows I ought up
sitting like Edith Ann and then I'll
only tomlin in the big chair and every
time I sit somewhere I'm like pretty
sure that's what it looks
I know coz tall people always complain
about me on planes but short people it
sucks cuz you lose your circulation just
feet don't touch the floor yeah sure
it's difficult for short pedia I don't
call people problems you are perfect
how did this come about and like what
are you most excited about the show kind
of all of it I mean when it first came
up I was like no I shouldn't do that
that seems nice
yeah but you do start to feel like
that's not really what I do and I don't
want to like screw it up for kids was my
main thing of like all these great kids
are coming on I'm like I'm not gonna be
weird we're gonna say something that
they're like that's odd character he'll
be fine a wig but when we kind of
started messing because we've really
changed the format and I'm like I want
it less performer like performance
driven and more like what are these kids
up to and what are the kids that are
just like they're just doing things and
they're so in their own skin it's such
an early age and I'm like there's I
don't know I just think there's so much
people get so much attention for for
really being cruel and then you have
kids like Ella who was the the kid
governor for Connecticut she's so funny
she's exactly like her 11 year old self
and a kid and look at that face I mean
she's still look at the eyebrows know
she's such a right just attitude she
goes I want my kids to read about hatred
and what my homophobia is in the
textbooks because I want them to not
know what it is she was I was just like
I'm sorry what
yeah she's like I want them to read
about it in history for me to have to
explain it to them that's what my goal
is and I'm like
[Applause]
[Music]
and all these so many like their heart
is so big and their conviction so strong
yeah and and it's a big thing at any age
to just be like I know it's not what
everybody's doing but I'm okay with it
to see the world yeah their eyes is it
would be wonderful [ __ ] using stop
and slow down yeah I would like just
like a non aerosol spray I guess the
best thing it was just to be like I
would love to just be like you see mean
like just very weird may see people
that's why they obviously wanted you to
because you have a very great heart but
you're also very humorous and you have
kids and do your kids like speaking of
your kids are they little big shots they
do stuff that really shocked you and
they shocked me a lot yeah they're I
mean they're perfectly weird and funny I
mean Ben and my husband is like much
quieter in malware but he's super weird
I'm not gonna let him off the hook and
our kids are this weird amalgamation of
us and then you really start to see
their own selves come in so I see me
I see met Ben yeah I always think I'm
like if I just don't screw you up he'll
be amazing like if I had it my way I
would stuff them both in baby but you're
like a kangaroo for sure I'm always like
just sit up here and my my oldest is 12
but she's my height now and I'm
literally always like that's just odd
we're in this ain't like I'm wearing
your shoes I don't want to sit on your
lap
[Applause]
nothing gives us all the feels like our
families and friends so if you're up for
it I'd love to school scroll through
your Instagram and you've a great
Instagram I want to meet some of your
family and friends is that cool
sure okay let's do it okay here we go
let's see the first one oh my gosh that
is a long time ago what we look like
kids in that it's a way explain this to
us I think that Ben and I oh god I bet I
bet we had just we met have been a
Groundlings that Improv Theater
that's where we met in class and I bet I
mean I don't I don't think I was
probably still we were both still in our
20s for sure Wow which I look at that we
were sleeping full through nights
wonderful Oh God I'd like to explain me
sadly I'd like to say the one with the
tiny hat which by the way was from
Barbie western where I'd love to say it
was a joke or a character who'd woodson
I was told if I when I got to LA because
I had only done clays in New York and I
meant with I finally was like I'm
getting a commercial agent there like I
wasn't but I was going to meet with
someone and he said if you want to work
in this town you've got to do character
shots and I was like oh I think those
made me uncomfortable I said is that
when someone's like in that cop jacket
and then the next thing there was a
burglar and I was like I don't I don't
think I wanted to do that and he's like
well then you don't want to work and you
can't work with me but I didn't know
what was supposed to be like things you
may get cast as like a waitress or a cop
yeah so I went to do that headshot and I
was like this is Carole she works at the
Von's
she says what you can't see is under the
picture I'm holding a plastic tray with
Velveeta slices on it
and I had a whole thing I was like she
works says that in a grocery store at
the end of an aisle and she passes out
cheese samples it's about to whip up
some Rotel and I brought this back to my
agent and he's like he's like what does
this mean to anyone I'm like I don't
know I said it it stands Hodgins sure
did I no one ever called me in on that
because they look crazier lost that's
what I say like the Oscars luncheon
what's the Oscars luncheon if it's like
a fever dream
it's I might show up and you're just
like someone's gonna ask me to leave in
a minute but wait when I if you're
nominated there's like an Oscars
luncheon and you go and like it's just
like the nominees there and you can
bring a date and I brought my mom sandy
that's awesome hey sandy
okay next oh my god I love her hair her
just permed so many perms back then no
mini purse that's my sister Margie and I
bet I'm in grade school maybe she's in
high school and we just did lots of
perms and then just so much all met and
oh my god Aqua Net you hold it out with
the dryer crispy oh yeah ringlet yep
and then sometimes you'd only get to see
here and you'd get tired yeah these
ringlets in the back was just like look
I got a little version of a mullet down
time hair like if we were like going out
down tired and so Texan oh my god oh my
gosh I love him no you make some choices
sometimes it's a nice denim choice it's
my I think my mom and dad were like we
want to have nice pictures of you girls
taken and we're matching denim shirts
and do like the Pozzo like the cop
poster back to back I love it it's very
Charlie's Angel it's sure yeah sure
without any of the the coolness I love
denim girl you're talking to a text I
love Jenna but somehow we've gone off
the mark on that oh my gosh they're
little lions they are they
that's that still harmer Harper and
Homer that golden retriever golden
retrievers and I got these like Amazon
lion things and when they showed up and
they're made of like just old syringes
they're terrible colors as my dog's
sorry I put them on I was like out in
the backyard trying to get too crazy
like one year all dogs to sit still and
then he ond and I'm like yep yep that's
I go around again I know they truly look
like lions I god you're dying you're
laughing wait what's happening
that is my two of my dearest friends in
the world it's Brian Atwood he's a
fantastic shoe designer and then Michael
McGraw that we I went to high school
with Brian Michael we met I met on the
floor Jasper of the Palladium in the 90s
and I marched up to him and said that's
the ugliest jacket I've ever seen I love
it and we've never been apart oh my god
what you're laughing at no worries but
not at a time worthy it's very sir not
day time worthy I can't find me that is
probably what we look like 90% of the
time oh what a great
those are great friends they were both
my advice for my wedding oh my gosh
that's awesome
I hope you asked him to wear the jacket
we're not number I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this